ben shapiro is editor-in-chief of daily
wire.com and the host of the ben shapiro
show great to have you with us Ben
what's your reaction to the new texts I
mean it all depends on what the context
is so it seemed like the original
context people thought it had to do the
clinton investigation now it seems like
the opposite has to do with general
russian interference in the election but
until we have the context it's it's hard
to know whether this is something
important or not what we do know is that
struck in Paige were motivated against
the president they didn't like the
president how that manifested in their
behavior is something unclear it's
pretty clear by the way that the FBI and
the DOJ were working hand in glove with
top members of the Obama administration
with regard to the Hillary Clinton
investigation a lot earlier than this
when it came to Loretta Lynch for
example working with James Comey it's
hard to believe that the President of
the United States would go on national
television say you didn't know anything
about Hillary's private server at the
same time that he was emailing her at
her private email address and obviously
that was a serious problem I think for
him and for the FBI and for the DOJ but
as far as these specific texts they may
turn out to be nothing we just don't
know yet all right I want to play a
little bit of what he told our Chris
Wallace this is back in April of 2016 as
a lot of these things were ramping up
here's what he said about getting
involved or not getting involved with
investigations I do not talk to the
Attorney General about pending
investigations I do not talk to FBI
directors about pending investigations
the we have a strict line and always
have maintained it for presidents just a
button is up I guarantee it you I
guarantee that there is no political
influence in any investigation conducted
by the Justice Department or the FBI not
just in this case but in any case so Ben
do you take him at his word there yeah I
didn't take him at his word you know
what when he said it and I didn't take
him at his word before these texts came
out because there were other texts from
Paige instruct talking specifically
about going easy on Hillary Clinton
because she might be elected president
to the United States so this this latest
round of texts again seems to me almost
irrelevant I think it's the earlier
texts that make more of a difference
with regard to the Hillary investigation
meanwhile we're getting new information
today that relates to the FISA
applications and warrants with regard to
the steel dossier looking into
quarter-page we've gotten a lot more
information now from this memo
that came from senators Grassley and
Graham outlining not only what we'd
heard in the house memo but it seems to
add detail to that and some texture to
that as well what do you make of those
revelations I mean they don't seem new
but they seem like they seem to bolster
the later memo that came out from the
house Intel committee they do add some
depth of accusation and allegation to
the actual Lunas memo well what they
essentially allege is that there are
Hillary Clinton advocates friends who
are in Libya who are funneling
information to the State Department
after Hillary Department after Hillary
left obviously but there were still
people she'd worked with and the State
Department was then funneling that
information to Christopher Steele who's
then packaging that information and
handing it over to the FBI if that's the
case it looks like the State Department
was being used as a go-between for bad
information pushed forward by Hillary
Clinton allies including perhaps Sidney
Blumenthal if Trey Gowdy's implication
means anything if that's the case then
one of two things could be true either
there could be some sort of corruption
inside the FBI the FBI knew that this
was bad info they didn't check it and
they were so out to get the Trump
campaign that they decided to open a
FISA warrant on Carter page out of
suspicion and basically just gin
something up the other possibility is
that they were actually suspicious of
Trump they're actually suspicious of
Carter page and they decided to to cut a
few corners and use information they
didn't know was completely good in
getting the Carter page application if
that's the case if that's if that's what
happened the latter thing then we
actually have a broader problem with
FISA applications and FISA courts not
just with regards to this specific
application
all right meanwhile and we're all hoping
we get those spice applications at some
point cuz it would clear up a lot I mean
while you I don't think it would be a
good idea for the president to sit down
with Special Counsel Moeller as he is
now moving forward with his
investigation you said this you said no
lawyer including Jill Pesci and my
cousin Vinnie with the full-on clown
velvet suit which is one of my favorite
visuals ever would allow President Trump
to get into a room with Robert Muller it
would be the height of stupidity to do
this but he is chomping at the bit to do
it you know that well I mean if the
lawyers have to take him down to the
basement of the White House and
physically change them up to prevent
them from talking to Muller
I would recommend that beyond the table
so long as they don't violate his
consent in any way because that would be
illegal but it would be such a mistake
just as a lawyer it would be such a
mistake to put somebody like President
Trump who likes to blow v-eight who
likes to exaggerate who likes to say
that everything is the biggest the
strongest the best that you just the
most
incredible put that in front of a
trained lawyer like Rob Ramallah a
trained investigator like Robert Muller
who's going to sit there trying to pick
apart statements but Bill Clinton was a
very good lawyer and a very smart guy
when it came to manipulating language
and he got caught in a perjury trap by a
special investigator it's not hard to
see how President Trump gets caught in
some sort of perjury trapper obstruction
trap by the FBI Ben Shapiro thank you
very much by the way I'm gonna have to
check out my cousin Minnie again this
weekend just some of the best courtroom
scenes ever in history Ben Thanks
absolutely thanks so much